well let's review a little bit
everything that we've we've covered so
far so what was the Maclaurin series
representation of e to the X and once
again you'll have to take my word for it
that the Maclaurin series representation
really does equal when you take the
infinite series it really does equal e
to the X and I mentioned in a previous
video that I was thinking about the
proof and I finally gave up because I
couldn't think of the proof and then I
looked it up and then I realized why I
couldn't think of the proof it's quite
involved but I will do it eventually
probably after I cover a lot of other
things just because it's not something
that you really have to know to succeed
well in calculus or appreciate what
we're about to do but I will do it'll
probably take five or six videos anyway
back to where we were so the Maclaurin
series representation of e to the X and
it actually does equal e to the X is 1
plus X plus x squared over 2 factorial
plus X to the third or three-factor I'm
going to a bunch of terms and you'll see
why X to the fourth over 4 factorial
plus X to the 5 over 5 factorial plus X
to the sixth over 6 factorial plus X to
the seventh over 7 factorial plus X to
the eighth over 8 factorial and just
this is a factorial and it just keeps
going on and on to infinity right only
where you take the infinite series does
that exactly equal e to the X fair
enough well what was the Maclaurin
series representation of cosine of X
cosine of X cosine of X well that
equaled and I'm going to space them out
a little in a certain way and I think
you'll see why it equaled 1 plus x
squared over oh no sorry 1 minus this is
a minus sign let me erase that because I
want to make this as neat as possible it
equals 1 minus x squared over 2
factorial earned that two videos ago
plus X to the 4th over 4 factorial
- X to the sixth over 6 factorial might
already know where I'm going with this
plus X to the eighth over eight
factorial and it just when kept going
the next digit would be a minus out here
and it goes to infinity right but that
pattern you know the pattern and what a
sine of X what's the Maclaurin series
representation for sine of X well sine
of X it equals X minus X to the third
over 3 factorial plus X to the fifth
over 5 factorial minus X to the seventh
over 7 factorial and it just keeps going
you'd have an X to a ninth out here but
it goes on for infinity right these all
go on for infinity but you know the
pattern so let's just pause here because
this is this is I mean I think if you
understand what's going on one of the
few things in life that will truly give
you chills it'll truly make you believe
that there is a a order to the universe
that we as human beings can only take
catch a glimpse of we have limited Minds
but we are on the verge we're scraping
the surface here but there's something
amazing here cosine of X and sine of X
each of there
each of their Maclaurin series
representations or if if you were
essentially to write them as polynomials
each of them looks like it's almost like
part of e to the X right it's almost
every other digit and they wouldn't be
the same except for a couple of sign
changes so let me let me make that clear
so what if I were to define the function
cosine of X plus sine of X cosine of X
plus sine of X what would that equal or
what would its Maclaurin series
representation of that be well and n we
know we know that it's also equal well
it's essentially adding these two rows
so it'd be 1 plus X minus x squared over
2 factorial minus X to the third Oh
three factorial plus X to the fourth
over 4 factorial plus X to the fifth
over 5 factorial minus X to the sixth
over 6 factorial minus X to the seventh
over 7 factorial plus X to the eighth
over 8 factorial it just keeps going
right the next one would be a plus but
it goes on to infinity now I think it
should be clear to you that something
that the Goosebumps should be emerging
on your arm because look at this and
look at E to the X what's the difference
well it's just a couple of negative
signs here there if you if you take 3 of
this let me let me do it in a slightly
brighter color we have this negative
sign so the only difference between this
function and this function are these
negative signs and and and and I'll you
know I've seen this before I've learned
this before people for you know for
hundreds of years have known this but
I'll tell you something no one even
though they can prove it mathematically
no one really understands why this is
why we take these these trigonometric no
metric functions that appear you know
when we take the ratios of the sides of
a right triangle or the unit circle
definition and you know it's useful for
you know triangle measure that's
trigonometry right that's that's where
we came up with this cosine and sine
functions and it's related to the circle
and all the rest that the that when you
add these two fundamental functions
together from trigonometry right because
tangent is really just the ratio of the
sine to cosine so these are really what
trigonometry is the basis of Trianon
when you add their polynomial
representations together it's almost
exactly almost exactly except for these
negative signs the polynomial represent
a to the X and E and the number E and
first of all this is an exponent these
are no exponents here and E is just it
comes it's it's it's completely
unrelated or at least you want to think
from trickin trigonometry right he is we
got e from compound interest you'll see
that it's related to exponential growth
exponential decay when you know when you
have continuous
exponential growth and decay continuous
compound interest it's this number that
that is in a completely unrelated field
of not just mathematics but really the
universe right continuous interest
versus the ratios of a right of the
sides of a right triangle so so this
should already you know would be be
getting you thinking but what would be
even more amazing is if we could somehow
work with these to make them work a
little bit more equal well the only
thing that's the difference is are these
negative signs right so do we know
anything else in mathematics and our
mathematical tool kit that has this
pattern where it goes positive positive
negative negative positive positive
negative negative and it has this
essentially the cycle of four well you
might be thinking on it this will even
give you larger goosebumps or make your
your current ones bigger then the number
I or the unit imaginary unit I so what
what are the powers of I this is a
little review if this is completely
unfamiliar to to you you should re-watch
the imaginary numbers video so what are
the powers of i well i does the 0 is 1 i
to the first is I I squared is negative
1 I to the third power that's negative 1
times I so it's negative I negative I I
to the fourth power is I times negative
I so the eyes become negative 1 and then
you have a negative there so it becomes
1 and the pattern repeats itself I to
the 5th is I I to the sixth is negative
1 we learned this before but it's just
review I to the seventh is negative I I
to the 8th then becomes 1 again so there
you have just what this shouldn't you
know this is amazing
I has that property where every the the
second to in the cyclic or negative
right we have a negative number here
this is not necessarily a negative
number it's a negative imaginary but but
we have that negative sign so it looks
pretty similar right then we have two
positives that we have a negative and a
negative
and something else is interesting going
on here wherever we see the imaginary
number
whenever see an eye or negative i-ight
or a negative eye which terms do they
correspond to
well they correspond to the terms of
sine of X right it corresponds to that
term negative I corresponds to that term
I corresponds to that term negative I
corresponds to that term so we have
something it seems a little bit even
even even more of a pattern but anyway I
just realized I only have 40 I start to
I mean I have to say I'm normally pretty
smooth in these videos but when I start
talking about what I'm talking about
right now I starts to go in circles
because this is I've actually even heard
you know this this what were what we're
about to touch on as as proof of the
existence of God and really that's not
that much of an exaggeration
it is definitely proof of the existence
of some hidden order of the universe
that we can only catch a glimpse of and
maybe you can call that God but anyway I
want to get metaphysical on you but I
will see you in the next video